and of course now I suppose there'll be
a whole new generation of kids who fall
in love with this Mary Poppins and so
Emily are your kids how are they with it
well I think um I mean my youngest my
two year old has a sort of attention
span of fly so she watches the trailer
but hazel who's almost five has seen it
and just absolutely loved it and sort of
wants to talk about it all the time now
and yeah it was really weird it's your
mother's Mary Poppins I do think she's C
I think she just thinks it's normal
she's like well that's what this is what
Sunny's mummy does and this is what my
mummy does you know it's just sort of
like quite conversational for her is it
gonna help or hinder discipline at home
Oh hinder really yeah I think so because
she knows she already knows I can't fly
she's not what she's paid but she did
ask me to do the voice the other day
just out of nowhere because she was
quite sort of impassive watching the
film just sort of didn't just sort of
didn't reveal much of what she felt and
then the other day she goes do your
she's American of course sounds American
she goes she goes she goes do your Mary
Poppins voice and I go spit-spot and off
we go and she goes where I say to the to
the dolphin no no not yet and now the
two of them go no not yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
you